il ya quelques années l'expression
police de proximité était très à la mode
or vous allez le voir sur cette photo il
ya policiers du spvm qui a pris
l'expression homos en se collant un peu
trop à une citoyenne vous voyez karen
bastien la photo du policier une photo
compromettante donc et de cette femme a
enflammé les médias sociaux aujourd'hui
oui effectivement on peut peut-être en
sourire l'on peut sourire mais du côté
du service de police de la ville de
montréal on ne trouve pas ça très drôle
à faire lorsqu'on a vu la faute au spvm
on se demander si ce n'était pas une
blague une photo à modifier mais après
avoir entendu la jeune dame qui a pris
la photo à la radio ce matin les
policiers ont commencé à faire des
recherches et ont retrouvé ce policier
du poste de quartier 21 ceci vous
centre-ville de montréal
la photo a été prise donc à l'angle de
la rue saint-laurent et ontario
boulevard saint-laurent et rue ontario
ce qui est incroyable riz et rend con
c'est simplement parce que ça en plein
centre ville
effectivement il ya beaucoup de gens à
cet endroit là donc le policier a dû
dialoguer avec son supérieur
c'était ce matin alors effectivement il
ya des mesures vous avez droit de rire
il ya des mesures disciplinaires donc
qui ont été entreprises contre ce
policier politique ya six ans
d'expérience au sein du service de
police de la ville de montréal sous
l'évier ont pu écouter ian lafrenière
d'un commandant au spvm nature et ce
matin vers 9 heures une dame qui était
moyen la radio 10 1 où se sentait pas
assez à quel moment
rapidement je faisais un temps d'une
heure on savait de qui séchait de quel
point ici ils avaient été rencontrés
pour nous il s'agit d'un dossier de
discipline eternal a d'ores et déjà on
sait qu'il y aura sanction ça peut aller
jusqu'à une suspension et karen son
coéquipier pourrait lui aussi faire face
à des mesures disciplinaires il était la
loose
il était là effectivement parce que ces
policiers patrouillent donc en duo ils
étaient deux à bord de la voiture
patrouille où était son collègue
plusieurs rumeurs qui ont circulé
aujourd'hui mais le service de police de
la ville de montréal n'a pas confirmé ou
était l'autre policier à ce moment là il
ya enquête bien sûr lui aussi devraient
dialoguer avec son superviseur et
peut-être devra faire face à des mesures
disciplinaires pour aller jusqu'à la
suspension
voilà merci karim
à voir